Hey everyone, so today we will speak a little bit about the decentralized AI and specifically about the beat bridge
So here is where the everything starts. It's a github repository. It's
Public available. You can just go using this link and you will see
The code itself and the documentation to it. So what is beat bridge? It's the
decentralized AI network that is built on top of the bit tensor infrastructure
and the
subnet is basically the
Project. So this project is for New England energy demand
Prediction and here is the high-level workflow how everything works behind the scenes
there is
two main
Two main actors the validators and miners and
Validators basically they
Send the challenge to the miner and the challenge they just ask a miner. Hey miner
Can you please make a prediction was the energy demand gonna be in next?
five minutes for example and
miner
they see okay the validators asking me to make a prediction for this timestamp and the miner using the
machine learning model or any prediction model making a prediction and
Send it back to the validator and then when validator got the actual information. What is the
real energy demand
Was and this particular timestamp then it has the actual data and predicted data by the miner
So here is the validator using incentive mechanism it it evaluate it evaluates miners
performance and
send
Weights to the bit tensor blockchain. So in the blockchain it contains all the
All the rewards for the miners
Yeah
Here is a quick start how to make everything crime
so we will work mostly on the miner side because the validators is the maintains team and
Validators they are already deployed. So here is how to use this github repository. Here is the
initial read me file
Here you can see the guy the
Workflow on the high level the checklist what you should do
You can use this checklist to be sure that you are working
step by step and that you didn't miss anything and
Also, if you face any issues, you can identify
Exactly where it happened. Okay, I was I will take a pause here